I am at Zubrod Little Nell in Aspen
Colorado here cooking amazing brunch for
patron secret dining society at this
amazing house doing amazing food amazing
cocktails
it's Jazz Fest weekend we have a really
exciting scavenger hunt our guest right
now are looking for clues to find out
where their destination is and then our
next clue will lead them here to this
beautiful house we came up with a lot of
Mexican influenced items because of what
we like to eat with patron and we have a
solid just pairing some fun cocktails
with this should make it a lot of fun so
today is a great experience of these
masters of their craft in the realms of
culinary and mixology well thank you
very much we try to cook food that
dreams are made of it's been great to
come up here to Aspen when I first came
to saw this property is like I totally
want to make drinks here because it's
ridiculous mine style was really
inspired by classic cocktails and our
surroundings were here for the patron
secret dining society beyond this door
secret blue water prawns cuz we going
for quite a hurry up late to redoing
course one do they really bloody Maria
yep deconstructed let's make a salad out
of it right
this cocktail that you have with this
first course is a black tea infused
iroko reposado tequila with apricot
marmalade and grapefruit juice see -
that's going good yeah what do you got
for us today
we had some fun hors d'oeuvres we're
working on a riff on a seven-layer bean
dip and then got some queso fundido with
some chorizo stuffed squash blossoms
this dish is a riff on a chilaquiles
dish a dish originated in Mexico with
leftover tortillas from the night before
so we actually made fresh ones for you
and I have a little duck fetish and so
you have confit in here with the
farm-fresh duck egg on top and the
pairing for this is really phenomenal
everyone knows a Moscow Mule this is
just so much better because it's tequila
and I made a fresh ginger and sage soda
with the Roca silver little bit of lime
juice some basil seeds for your omega
threes to keep you focused throughout
the day the inspiration behind this
dessert was a classic churro so we
decided to incorporate a lot of citrus
and then we use the XO coffee and infuse
that with a little bit of orange noir
chocolate from Verona this was the first
cocktail that I thought of because I
stepped out here I thought about
Colorado and how beautiful the Rockies
are this is the Roca on yaho with DRAM
apothecaries pine syrup which is made
from fresh pine needles and citrus
medica bitters enjoy it's a great thing
to work with one company because you can
get familiar with their flavor profiles
so let's you really get creative with
yours
so right now we're weave wraps with
brunch and we've got a couple of dessert
cocktails for everyone that we're
serving by this beautiful little lake
and dragon deer is playing some tunes
serving some cocktails and just having
fun that's the tortilla that's a burrito
that's a wrap